la carcasse de l'édifice patrimonial
incendié dans le centre-ville historique
de Lima fumait encore ce matin avec des
risques de propagation un incendie qui
n'avait rien à voir avec la
manifestation mais qui a permis à la
police de les expulser du centre-ville
les quelques 7000 manifestants venus du
sud sur retourner logées chez des
sympathisants nous sommes ici à viel
Salvador une banlieue pauvre de Lima un
ancien bidonville d'un demi million
d'habitants
issus des mêmes régions des favorisées
que les manifestants leurs
grands-parents ou leurs parents sont
surtout des Quechua qui ont fui la
pauvreté vers une vie meilleure Halima
ou près de Lima c'est le cas d'Adrian
rimaska un jeune élu local qui a
participé à la prise de Lima la veille
nous les comprenons parfaitement nous
savons que les différences avec Lima
sont immenses et que leurs qualités de
vie est terrible
sont tous des paysans de Cusco hébergé
par un foyer d'aide sociale de rien de
Salvador ils ont quitté leur travail
leur famille pour revenir à leurs frais
réclamés à Lima la démission de la
présidente par intérim Dina bollwerté et
une nouvelle constitution ils ne sont
visiblement pas financés par des
intérêts occultes ou des organisations
terroristes comme certains le
sous-entendent ils sont inquiets ils
croient qu'ils ont été dénoncés et ils
s'apprêtent à se réfugier ailleurs de
peur d'être jugé condamné en vertu de
l'état d'urgence
à Cusco d'où ils viennent et
manifestations les affrontements
continuent ou lancer de pierre et de
bouteilles la polystes avec des gaz
lacrymogènes il y a des blessés mais pas
de mort comme un Puno
c'est là que se trouvent les deux
dernières victimes on en compte 45
depuis le début du conflit en décembre
Adrien dit qu'il n'avait pas le choix
trop d'injustice et de mépris des élites
de Lima c'est trop
alors tout a éclaté nous sommes fatigués
de tout ça au point de se lancer dans la
rue et d'aller à la capitale
et de partir pour le deuxième jour pour
la prise de Lima